-Welcome back to our show.
-I'm happy to be here.
-Thanks for always coming on.
You know we love you here.
Man, you're phenomenal in
"The Batman."
-Thank you.
-You were unbelievable.
I can't wait to get in
and talk to you about that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm just so happy.
I'm like, "Go, Zoe! Go!"
You just crush it.
But I also -- It's a big --
That's this weekend.
It's going to be
the biggest movie.
I'm so excited about it.
Then, next weekend, you're
hosting "Saturday Night Live."
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Why are you -- Why would you
put this much pressure
on yourself?
-I don't know.
This was a
horrible, horrible plan.
-Yeah, because then you can only
enjoy that for a week,
because you've got to get right
into -- It's a lot work.
-I'm so scared and so excited.
I keep on asking, like,
friends of mine who have hosted.
I'm asking for
some comfort or something.
-Yes.
-And I tell them I'm scared.
And they all say,
"You should be scared."
-Oh, my God. No, no, no.
-Not one person
has said like, "Just relax.
You're going to be fine."
-Oh. I'm going to tell you right
now, you're going to be so fine.
You're awesome. You got this.
-Will you come do
a skit with me?
-Yeah, of course.
I would do anything with you.
Yeah.
-Really?
-I would do anything
you want me to do.
You don't have to ask twice.
-Okay.
-You kidding me?
-Put you on the
spot in front of everybody.
-The stuff that we've done on
our show together, yeah,
the least thing I can do is
do you one favor.
Yeah.
-That would be amazing.
-If you ever need --
But I'm telling you,
you're going to be set.
You don't need me.
You have -- It's the best cast.
They have the
best writers, producers.
You're in good hands.
-I'm just scared I'll,
like, slip or something.
-No! On live TV?
That would never happen.
Oh, my God.
I think you're going to nail it.
I think you're just a natural.
Every time you come on the show,
you just steal the whole show.
We all love you.
-Aww, you're very sweet.
-But you really --
But you are --
Honestly, this thing just
kind of went around recently.
It's footage that --
-Oh, boy.
-Yeah, it's -- No, it's great.
-It's cute.
-Okay.
-It's you as a child.
-Being a ham.
-Yeah, but you were being --
Where were you at?
At a VH1 thing or something?
-Yeah, my dad, I think,
was doing an interview for VH1,
and I think he went to
the bathroom,
and then I was like,
"It's my turn!"
-And you were 7 years old.
-Something like that.
-And they were like,
"Hey, while your dad's away --"
-They're like,
"Who is this child?"
-Yeah, they're like,
"Can you sing something?"
And you just hopped up,
and you're like,
"I'm going to do 'No Scrubs.'"
This is real. Check this out.
Here's baby Zoe Kravitz.
-♪ I don't want no scrubs ♪
♪ A scrub
is...get no love from me ♪
♪ Sittin' on the passenger side
of his best friend's ride ♪
♪ Trying to holler at me ♪
-Yeah!
-"Am I on TV?"
-Why am I wearing a tiara?
-Yeah, why were you wearing --
-I don't know.
-Because you're just a cute --
"Am I on TV?"
-"Am I on TV?"
-The cutest kid ever. Come on.
Let's talk about "The Batman,"
because last time, I think,
you were here,
you were filming, and --
You were in
the middle of filming.
You can't say anything,
obviously, no spoilers.
-Yep.
-But this is two years
in the making.
-Yeah, I got the job in 2019.
-Wowzers.
-And then we got down for
six months because of COVID.
And, yeah,
it's been a long journey.
-Yeah.
-It's been wild.
-And did you know that you were
going to be up for Catwoman?
Did you --
How did this come about?
-No.
-Did you push for it and you're
like, "I got to do this"?
-No. I got a phone call.
My agent told me that
I was on the list of actors
they were looking at.
And even that
would have been enough.
To be on that list
was pretty wild.
And then I flew out
to L.A. to meet
Matt Reeves, the director,
and loved him
and just loved his vision.
-How is he?
-He's a wonderful human,
wonderful director,
cares so much.
He wrote the script, as well.
So, I was just --
I just wanted to work with him.
-And did you know
Robert Pattinson before?
-I knew Rob.
I knew Rob just from --
I don't know -- around.
-Been around? Yeah.
-Yeah, around.
-But had never worked with him.
And I'm a huge fan of his work.
And I had to camera-test with
him, and that was kind of funny.
Just to camera-test
with someone you know
dressed up as Batman, and you
haven't seen them a while --
-He was dressed as Batman?
-Yeah, they put him in, I think,
George Clooney's suit.
But then you kind of catch up.
You know, you're like,
"So, how you been, you know?"
-He's like, "I'm alright.
Yeah, yeah. No, yeah.
-"I'm Batman."
-"Oh, yeah,
I'm Batman, I guess."
Yeah, yeah."
It's wild.
But -- Wait.
So, you do the screen test.
You walk in,
he's dressed as Batman?
-Yeah. Only from the waist up,
by the way.
He was wearing sweatpants
at the bottom.
-Oh, my God!
You've seen something no one's
ever seen --
Batman wearing sweatpants.
-Like, casual Batman.
-Casual Batman.
That's in the sequel.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Wait. So, you go in, you go,
"Oh, my gosh."
That's -- I mean,
that's acting right there.
I mean, you got to go in there,
and you're like,
"Hey, let's just go for it,
because I know you,
and now you're Batman."
-Like, he was so good that
I actually --
I was so scared that I was
gonna just be thinking like,
"Oh, my God.
It's Rob dressed as Batman.
That's weird."
-Yeah.
-But he was so wonderful that
I totally forgot it was him,
actually,
which was really impressive.
-Yeah, he, honestly, is amazing.
But you're amazing,
as well, in this.
It just all works.
And I --
You just go into this world
and you forget who --
That you know anyone.
I'm like, "Oh, these are just
great actors in this."
-Oh, I'm so happy to hear that.
-Oh, I loved it.
And I was like, "Okay, now, if I
was cast as Catwoman --"
-Which you might --
Which you still might be.
-I was on the list.
-You're still young, Jimmy.
-My agent called me, as well.
I know. I was so nervous.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
Don't get me
in the room with Rob."
Oh, my God.
"Because I'm wearing
sweatpants, as well."
But I would
study -- I would study cats.
-I did that.
-I would drink milk
out of a bowl.
-I did that.
-You did not.
-I did.
-You drank milk out of a bowl?
-Maybe.
I'm method, dude.
-Me too, man.
Dude, I'm so into --
You don't --
Well, I mean, no spoilers.
Yeah, anyways...
-I hung out with cats.
-Yeah.
-A lot.
-See, that's where I'm --
As I'm thinking now,
I think I'm allergic to cats.
-Which is why --
Which is the only reason
you didn't get this part.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-And that's like --
But then also
more of a challenge for
the role for me.
But I would be like -- I do like
cats because they're curious.
I find them interesting.
I feel like they
could kill me any two seconds.
-I was really inspired by that.
I watched a bunch of cat videos,
feline videos,
watching them fight.
And what I was so interested by
was the fact that you can --
You can't read
their face at all,
which is why I think people
are kind of creeped out by them.
But you can't tell
what they're going to do.
-They go, "Oh, my gosh.
Kitty loves me."
-Yeah, Then, all of a sudden,
the kitty scratches
your face out.
-Kitty scratches
your face out, yeah,
and be like, "Get off,"
like, and then leaves.
-Yeah. They don't care.
-No, they don't --
-They don't care.
They were the hardest thing
to control during the shooting.
We were doing,
like, crazy stunts,
and, like, all that was fine.
But then, like, getting a cat to
stay in one place -- impossible.
Impossible.
-There's no actor cats.
-No. We -- I -- They tried to
get me to "know the cats"
that were Selina's cats.
And it's funny.
They would say, you know,
"Training at 1:30
and then rehearsal at this time
and then cat time."
And I was like,
"What's cat time?"
And it was just putting me in
a room with a bunch of cats,
with the cats that
were going to be my cats.
-Thinking that it might help.
-But the cats didn't care.
-No, they're cats.
-I was just sitting here,
and the cats
would just walk away.
It did nothing.
It did nothing for --
-They did -- Well,
they did great in the movie.
If the cats are watching,
you did a great job.
-You guys are amazing.
-When we come back,
I want to show a clip from
"The Batman."
More with Zoe Kravitz after
the break, everybody.